hi I'm Finn wolfhard and I'm about to go
undercover on the Internet and this is
actually me twitter mary says you said
you cut your chin on the desk in Jimmy
Fallon did they cover that up and
stranger things by you getting hurt on
the rock oh that's a great question
no they didn't but that would have been
a good writing point
no what I'm gonna get a addition to the
script if they did I know the duffer's
love adding stuff that actually happened
to us in real life into the show but now
they didn't replied krysta see Quinn is
Finn Wilfred okay why does he like
horror so much it's all coincidence but
I'm also a psychopath reddit how jumping
from cliff was made in season 1 Finn
Wolf's heart was made seen of Mike who
was forced by Troy jumping from cliff to
water then Jane comes broke Troy's arm
what our behind-the-scenes visual
effects or similarity or bungee jumping
thanks for answers it was a few things
it was a real cliff we could only stand
maybe 30 feet from the actual edge we
never got close to it it started with
the location I would walk off camera
they would cut they bought a fake cliff
with a mat underneath it and they shot
from below and I would walk up and look
down that's the shot where I'm looking
down off the cliff I then jump off onto
a mat but then cuts I'm suspended in the
air I am on a giant blue screen in
Atlanta Georgia being hung by my butt on
a giant wire and I'm being dragged up
like that it was fun for the first two
hours when you're kind of flying around
but then you realize that you're chafing
in places that you would never normally
chafe in in your entire life
so I was very happy with the finished
result posted more Twitter from Lindsay
advance is it just me or does anyone
else think that fin wolfhard would make
an excellent young Ben
it is not just you I would love to do
that but it just ended the series just
ended but you know I'm a free agent
Marvel and gives me I'm around Marvel
doesn't handle any well it's owned by
Disney anyways whatever hire me what
made you want to take on your role in
attorney I want to see it but looks so
scary oh well you're an awesome dude
Thank You Alicia I that's really nice of
you first of all and second of all I
thought that the turning was different
from any thriller or horror script I'd
read before I thought that all the
characters were very put together and
well-developed and I thought that Myles
the character that I play was weird and
unorthodox and I wanted to take it on
and try to play him he's the turning
based on the turn of the shrew well it
is based on the turn of the screw but
not the turn of the shrew Cora without
any spoilers who gives the best
performance on stranger things well I'd
like to say myself but I know I really
wouldn't I think David Harbor gives an
amazing performance I love when the
writers performance I love Joe Carey's
performance you know what scratch all of
that
I love everyone's performance in the
show if stranger things and a crossover
would Mike wheeler and Richie Tozier get
along because they're both in wool for
that is a great question Mike would hate
Richie Richie is much too abrasive for
Mike Mike is a really intense person too
so I think Richie would think he's
really intense and Mike would think
Richie's really dumb but maybe they
could you know if they had a mediator
maybe they could do it what would be the
ideal is an thesis and Jesus that's why
I'm an actor okay what would be the
ideal antithesis to Finn wohlfahrt
I guess what's think who is the opposite
of me and like any I guess anyone that's
not me that's a good right that's a good
answer
Yahoo Answers Bethany and what is the
show strainer things really about I've
read summaries in the description but I
just don't understand
no spoilers please why wouldn't you just
watch the show I don't understand
I had to go on Yahoo Answers to ask
people what it's about when you can't
you know I just watch the show Instagram
you may not believe it but it's actually
me here is me with the more Finn what
happened well sometimes when you have
long hair and you straighten it it looks
different so I'm not you know I'm not
sure this was for fun I wanted to do
something different with my hair and a
half the people liked it and apparently
half didn't I loved it posted Wikipedia
wolfhard got his first acting job from
Craigslist that is true I got my first
acting job from Craigslist um it wasn't
sketchy was for this local Canadian band
that needed a kid for their music video
that went up and I auditioned for it
with a bunch of young fun college kids
that were making it and directing it and
it was great I got the first job I ever
auditioned for I ended up booking but
part of that I think was just cuz I
looked like the lead singer I am DB Finn
admitted to having a fear of clowns
appropriate for playing Richie Tozier in
the new hit movie I don't not have a
fear of clowns it's not like my fear I
guess I might have said that in an
interview or two that's really because I
couldn't really come up with it better
response
I think clowns are scary on a surface
level but they're not my fall in fear
submit he plays the guitar the piano the
drums bass in there Monica that is all
true I do play all of those it's not
like I play them well but I do play them
technically anyone could say that they
play anything doesn't mean anyone plays
it well but I do play all that stuff
next more read it does anyone know which
guitar pills Finn uses that's a good
question I've do the same thing with
messages that I really like to try to
emulate there's Sam but that's really
nice that someone asked that right now
I'm using this thing called a distortion
feedback er it's made by boss and Kurt
Cobain used to use it lots of people
used to use it but that's one of the
noble names I also use a Holy Grail
reverb pedal I use a boss chorus and
tuner pedal mmm that's about it and then
Fender amp or something like that
seriously it's actually me his three
favorite films of the Graduate based
confused in melody that is all true
those are my three favorite films of all
time I have lots more that I love those
are some of my favorite films graduate
is probably yeah definitely
my number one and then it kind of
everything else melody is a movie that
I've never met anyone in my life who's
seen that movie other than me and my
parents but it's great okay that's it
signing off the internet